[Music]
another thing interesting happened this
week though that Matthew was quite
excited about
um the new Doctor
Who dropped the new Dro first the
trailer dropped the trailer dropped not
yet but the trailer dropped um this is
the first thing is this the first thing
they've done since the Disney deal or
was some of the stuff they did or some
of the last stuff they' done part no
this this will be the first production
they're doing with Disney because you
know the one thing that I really liked
about the thing I thought I was worried
about was with you know Mo Money Mo
Problems sort of thing um that that it
would look like an American TV show and
I was actually really impressed it
didn't well it doesn't
still yeah just it looks like they took
the nice cameras that they used for
season
13 um of Doctor Who and then used them
to film a good
story yeah oh my
God because I so I I liked the last
season it was it was it wasn't great it
was good it looked great and that's what
I liked about it it looked really nice
because they up the production quality
they got new fancy cameras and it was
great the story just lacked this looks
like they've just were like we've got
the cameras now let's write something
really good we've got David Tenant come
on we can do something good we can do
something good is how much impact is
like Doctor Who got in America though do
you guys know it's coming is it with the
Disney deal is it do you
care I mean for for me you know I mean I
see announcements you know all over
YouTube and
Facebook that it's coming um
other than it's coming I'm not really
sure where it's coming to because
there's so many places that have Doctor
Who there's a little bit Doctor Who on I
think is it Max and I know there's
Doctor Who on Pluto and then there's the
whole Doctor Who thing on Disney which I
really haven't sorted out in my head yet
but I know it's coming someplace and I'm
sure that I just keep logging on
somebody say oh my God it was the best
episode ever then I can go hun it down
when when the 60th anniversary drops
which is on
November
25th I think don't quote me on that but
I think it's November 25th that's when
the first one drops it's going on Disney
plus worldwide so everyone can see at
the same time
Thanksgiving is the BBC still involved
with making the Disney Doctor Who yeah
okay and you've got the bad wolf is
still third
sorry as I understand it you know BBC
still doing the production Disney's just
doing distribution oh cool yeah
BK yes they're not they're not producing
but they they have given them a lot of
money it's
the it's the money injection it's the
big deal um and that's what I was
worried about that they would spend it
but not spend it well and what what we
want them to do is spend it on improving
a little bit well we want to improve the
writing we want to get some better
actors in like um Patrick Harris I've
got Neil Patrick Harris Neil Patrick
Harris um who I adore um he was the best
thing in a million by a million miles
about the 10 things no so How I Met Your
Mother um challenge accepted um he was
about a million miles B was the best
thing um he was really good in um Lemony
Snicket on Series of Unfortunate Events
yeah he was big behind that he produced
it he big behind that um his Cameo and
Harold and Kumar Go to White Castle is
one of the best cameos of anything ever
he ended up cameo in almost all of them
and he's like he's not really gay
actually a massive womanizer and he uses
the gay thing to get to nail women I
love that they also good the mushroom
and White Castle though that's doesn't
get better I Stargate Troopers you know
he was
Troopers don't do uh uh sbog junr sign
me up for Stargate Troopers right now
right now come on um so they've got um
one of the main character one of the
main villains we don't know if it's a
villain yet is beat the Meep which is
that big alien with the big eyes it's a
alien that come from the comics like way
back in the 60s um that's making an
appearance in the 60th anniversary and
that is voiced by Miriam
Maro you know the one from Harry Potter
what's her name yeah she's nut SM about
frogs that woman she's crazy she's
crazy um
yeah Harry Potter what character mam I
can't remember her name she was the yes
yeah that
woman um
she saying some things about
uh uh Charles haen Savage who plays uh
Steve uh Steve Martin she was saying
that he was all bad and little shop to
Horrors or whatever and the director was
like what the hell is this lady saying
like everybody would loves Steve Martin
like he never did anything bad so I
don't know she's got herself in the in
the headlines right now she's she's a
little bit nuts um she's funny she's
very gloriously she's properly she's
eccentric because she's probably got
enough money to be eccentric and she's
old enough but she is nuts you ever seen
her in interview she's like oh my God on
Graham nordon
show it's so funny I'm nervous asking
this what no please don't be okay
because I will answer I know that's
that's what makes me nervous what your
she's the story she tells are amazing
yeah so good but yeah I'm excited that
she's gonna be in it so yeah I love that
and and like say Neil Patrick Harris is
great in everything so this is just this
I think this is glorious for him so um
and we'll get a nice transition from
David Tenant to Shu gwa and it'll be
great which by the way sex education
season 3 is out right now it is so good
it is so
good okay I'm not watch you watched it
you don't watch oh you need to watch it
it's so funny it's really they've gone
full in this
season
frontal I don't want I don't want to see
men's
Willies well don't watch the first
episode then Willies okay Boys season 3
episode one I was going to say quick cut
this conversation the bud because I know
what's coming in the comments shortly
and what what's coming Jay we're not
saying those words again all right I can
see Storm's braing ticking over because
he hasn't been listening and he's just
realized no somebody said you know first
episode of of the the bo season three
and there was a word that shot through
my head did not intersect with my mouth
but I did think of about
plug God's
sake
you sucked me in then I was just like
he's not going to do it that's great
that's you sucked me in then Dam
[Music]
it